welcome to this video playing grandma's
the orange neon it goes kufstein I guess
would be the right pronunciation from
from Israel and we have a two jacks game
here normally plays d 4 i'm pretty
pretty surprised that we actually get
this we have many methods and the in the
d4 openings with him being white so he's
in fact it's quite funny he's also
playing the zimage like I often do he's
also giving this a go quite quite often
tough tough tough tough tough tough
maybe here this is Bishop d3 I wanted to
do something else I normally played the
normal Italian game with Bishop c5 but I
wanted something different and with
within this complex I have not really
studied those modern continuations like
Bishop d3 I mean modern is always
relatively speaking in those openings
it's a let's say well forgotten um yeah
I have not studied that really under it
shows I really have to play this
basically over the bottom um okay so at
least he's losing some time here so
taking here it's got an ID far though
ticks ticks always get this nightie for
business going the aam that's not so
great you know my nightie on 101 f5 is
just just awful
yeah maybe still go here it's very tough
to play I can take and maybe play even
night f5 here 494 later now this does
not look good yeah i guess i need to
prevent 94 the big issue is since this
is this dreaded night i go here yeah
anyway he's got queen edge favia a
thought queen geforce maybe an idea or
queen g500 if I tweet if i take it cool
night x and g 5 I can try to maybe catch
this piece maybe try that need to go for
maximum activity here of course I don't
know how to tell obviously I'm it's such
a difficult dynamic position that you
can easily make mistakes and enter judge
things wrong maybe rookie mom yeah I
don't know can i hack I don't have a key
aid which is a real shame ok 5 and
possibly look at seven maybe I need to
go here also to to take take away
squares for the night we can eat 7s rook
f7 ok it's not doing that I can play
King f7 though and then look edge aid
and it's possible I guess he
our rookie age I think it's a kimchi
groups here with this night being sort
of silent it's it's maybe possible very
strange position Andrew P and this night
is cut off yeah if he goes gee for I
have f4 it's really cut off if i take
now on c3 and player for the night is
totally trapped it is just trapped but
what is the position like i mean i can i
can use my night okay i'm doing that now
come on i need to be good I here and now
night here see 584 really interesting
question
or is that some way to to attack here on
the on the pink side I don't think so
we have no idea what this position is
like I have no idea it's very
interesting I can do night be sick the
day 5 i'm not sure if he can make any
any sort of progress in this position
time warning without me really getting
substantial tall to play i can always
take see form
yeah that's it's a very risky business
trying to play that as a win for four
wide I don't really think it's possible
some some some is somehow play d4 but
it's very risky
I can very easily be better than hey I
didn't didn't see that move ah come on
check
and unbelievable to lose this no way
this was in any way better for white no
way is playing without this night on age
five frustrating really frustrating and
this should have been punished I'm
pretty sure actually I could punish this
was far too risky what he did maybe I'm
judging this wrong it's possible of
course but I don't think so yeah this is
just to Gen Y in this black me I'm not
sure I mean it's obviously complicated
but I don't really believe in letting
forward I forgot about the c5 idea yeah
maybe it is better for white maybe it is
the king and the pawns it's the thing is
I was always thinking that I have some
counter-attack against f2 but probably
this is simply not materializing but
computer gives us as a winner I don't
understand yet how exactly if i go here
how do you win this you go to the a pawn
ok that's too quick young I was always
thinking that that this gives me a play
but it seems to be too slow ok I need to
go with the King first for the sea poem
and it's too slow we aren't happy until
this promotes asses 5 moves that's the
problem and that's a problem I was too
optimistic yeah I thought that I would
have this counter play then the question
is if I should take on c3 how do i maybe
today I still don't believe this I'm
playing I have this this night is
paralyzed maybe something like did this
c5 the some sort of fortress should be
should be there should be the idea this
may be
maybe this somehow trying to keep keep
it closed a night on c5 here yeah this
is this is very close to a to a fortress
this in fact is a perfect fortress with
a 5 coming this is even better for black
according to the computer I need to cite
the right photo set up here what happens
if he is not taking this is Lucas 10
this isn't some and this is this is shot
on this is not an interesting young the
computer actually wants to do this and
claims this is equal 1 snow here once to
play this and then I can go to deform
yeah that's a big difference of course
yeah and he gives this as a draw for the
moment it's difficult to the computer
it's not clear that it is calculating
deep enough for some of the force lines
that might happens if white plays d4 and
tries to break through I really feel
like I should have something here at
least to keep it equal maybe it's then
maybe it's this you have a very very
tough very tough situation also also
what about if if I if I don't take my
night a form and then TC 3mb form thank
you for me ok taking it's probably right
yeah it's probably the wrong light setup
I thought that this would be good always
keeping this attack but that's probably
not the case
yeah it's obviously better there's an
idea that may fall okay thanks for
watching